I think you're going to love this next segment.
One of the big revelations of the last 10
days in the American political world is that
a Republican Congressman named Devin Nunez
is part of the problem rather than being someone
investigating the problem.
What I mean by that is Devin Nunez was part
of that group that was having meetings in
Europe, looking for dirt on Joe Biden, encouraging
others to smear Joe Biden all with the goal
of getting foreign help in, uh, Donald Trump's
reelection campaign.
It just so happens that Devin Nunez is also
on the house intelligence committee.
So in the impeachment hearings from two weeks
ago, three weeks ago, Devin Nunez was getting
to ask questions of witnesses when in reality
he should be a witness.
He is actually more of a co-conspirator rather
than an investigator.
But over the last week, it's actually gotten
even worse.
There is now a call log, which shows that
Devin Nunez was directly in touch on his phone
with not only Rudy Giuliani, Donald Trump's
lawyer, who's been spearheading lots of this
insanity, but also with a guy named Lev Parness.
Left Parness is one of Rudy Giuliani's key
henchmen and this entire thing and love partners
along with Igor Fruman were arrested while
trying to flee to Europe on one way tickets.
They've since been indicted.
Lev Parness is now cooperating with investigators
and says he was in touch with Devin Nunez
and he can demonstrate that Devin Nunez was
part of this entire thing.
So now we get this call log and the call log
corroborates.
There was contact between Nunez and Parness.
There was contact between Nunez and Juni Giuliani
and the whole lot of them.
So that gets us to a segment on Fox news yesterday.
I really, really love this.
There's a guy named Greg Jared, that's Greg
with two G's in case you're going to Google
that, who's been on Fox news for a very long
time and Donald Trump loves Greg Jarrett.
He has been talking up Greg Gerrit for months.
You will very often see Donald Trump retweet
quote legal analysis from Greg Garrett from
a guy named Mark Levin and from some other
people.
And Trump says, Greg Jarrett is really the
guy who understands what's going on.
He understands that, uh, I did nothing wrong
and Greg, Jared is going to be able to explain
it all to you.
So ask about this call log, which shows that
indeed left Parness and Devin Nunez and Rudy
Giuliani, Devin Nunez was in touch with them
and he's really more a part of the problem
than someone who can be investigating what
went on.
Jared suggests on Fox news, this is just amazing.
Without any evidence.
He says, you know, even the call log might
not really corroborate anything because someone
might've used Devin Nunez, his phone to make
those phone calls.
This is the most absurd that we've reached.
The limit of motivated reasoning.
We've reached the peak of baseless speculation
and just an abundant violation of the principle
of Occam's razor, which I'll get to in a second.
Checkout what Greg Jared had to say.
The only thing new that I picked out of yesterday's
was this communication between Devin Nunez,
Rudy Giuliani and the white house.
In what way, if any, is that problematic?
Well, we just don't know because we don't
know the details.
In fact, it's a call law.
Does that mean the Devin newness was actually
on the call or somebody else and we don't
know the import of it?
Um, you know, I frankly, I don't trust Adam
Schiff.
So absent any evidence, Jared introduces this
idea.
Maybe someone took Devin Nunez his phone to
make those phone calls, or I guess even less
believable would be maybe Nunez said to someone,
here, take my phone and call left parlor Parness
and Rudy Giuliani, whatever version you are.
A, I'm believing is what Greg Jarrett is suggesting
doesn't make any sense.
Now, fiction has become reality.
On Tuesday when the call log leaked, I saw
tweets sort of, I thought jokingly saying
they're going to come up with something like
it wasn't really Devin Nunez using the phone
or the call log was spoofed or someone hacked
his phone to make the phone calls and it really
wasn't Devin Nunez.
And then yesterday, Greg Jarrett actually
pulls that idea on national television and
suggests it and the most troubling thing about
it, I know you know where I'm going, is that
some people are going to fall for it, not
definitively, but it'll give them enough plausible
deniability so that even though there's no
evidence, they will say, well, okay, looks
like a call log corroborates what [inaudible]
has said, but do we know for sure that that
was Devin Nunez on the phone in the same way
that I might have been coerced into saying
something on this show?
Can you really believe what is what I'm saying
on this show?
Really what I think or did someone hold me
at gunpoint just off camera and forced me
to do it?
I guess it's possible, but absent any evidence,
why would we go to that outcomes raiser?
Which explanation fits what we know with the
fewest assumptions?
Well, Devin Nunez is known to be super sketchy
left.
Parness says he was in touch with Nunez.
The call record says Parness was in touch
with newness or maybe someone took Devin Nunez
his phone and called exactly the people that
left.
Parness says Nunez was in touch with in order
to falsely incriminate Devin Nunez or for
some other reason.
This is a suggestion that should be laughed
away until someone can come up with some evidence,
but otherwise we're in the world of, wow,
someone might fall for this.
Well, let's say it and see who we pull in
and unfortunately when you're dealing with
low information Trumpists, you're going to
pull some people in with this nonsense.
Incredible.
We'll follow up on this with a clip on our
Instagram page at David Pakman show on Instagram.
Make sure you're following us there while
you're there.
Follow me on Instagram too.
I, I'm posting stuff to, at David dot packets.
We'll take a quick break.
We'll be back right after this
with dr John Gartner with a new report and
then much more later on in the program